let's jump into this first story we've
got this from Vanity Fair Donald Trump
is now facing wait for it
136 years in prison now for those that
are tuning to the live show in about 10
minutes Trump will be delivering remarks
we have that stream ready to go I'm
going to move it out of the way so we
can monitor that and get ready for
Donald Trump's statement in the meantime
here's the story from Vanity Fair oh and
you know they're loving this they write
as you've no doubt heard by now Donald
Trump was charged on Tuesday with an
astonishing 34 felony counts of
falsifying business records in the first
degree now here's the thing it's the
same thing they charged them 34 times
for the same thing
as Maggie Haberman reported not only did
the ex-president look very unhappy as he
walked into the courtroom but he
appeared as angry as he did after the
axis Hollywood tape went public October
2016. why might Trump not have
cartwheeled into the courtroom with a
huge grin in his face snapping his
fingers and blowing Erica to the cameras
for one thing Tuesday marked what was
effectively the first time he'd ever
been truly held accountable for anything
in his life for another he's facing more
than 100 years in prison 34 Class E
felonies 136 years in prison which is an
incredibly huge number now my question
for this ridiculous article and for
these people is
are they happy that a misdemeanor
booking bookkeeping error is going to
result in two life terms
they don't care CNN ran a poll
and they asked do you believe this was
politically motivated almost everyone
said he has like 80 percent said yes
they said do you think it's a good thing
and they said yes they don't care
Democrats mostly Democrats said it was
good that for political reasons
two-thirds two-thirds two two-thirds of
America of respondents because you don't
know I don't know the details of the
poll but two-thirds of the respondents
to that poll are
are a belief something that is
antithetical to all liberal principles
it is wrong to use the government to go
after your political opponents because
they are the your political opponents
right that is that is straight up stuff
that happens in banana republics and the
reason that these countries are banana
republics is because of the organization
of their government they are illiberal
they try to do things like give
everything to everybody like trying well
hold on but they I gotta interrupt you
okay Banana Republic you know where it
comes from right go ahead it comes from
when uh what was it Nicaragua I think it
was or which country the United States
because oh because of the dope yeah the
right right right it's the US's
corporate intervention yeah but but but
I'm being a bit pedantic yeah we
understand usually Honduras in Costa
Rica there you go Honduras and coasters
usually they they are because they have
illiberal policies and even even the the
type of of corporate and and government
collusion that is also illiberal but
point taken yes to call them banana
republics but when they think he's
literally Hitler they've been told over
and over again you would do absolutely
anything to destroy literally Hitler and
that's what they think he is so they're
fine with it it doesn't matter what our
constitution says it doesn't matter what
our our justice system looks like it
doesn't matter if it has negative
consequences for even people on their
side going forward it doesn't do you
guys think we talked about this a moment
ago before the show started but I want
to ask now for everybody listening do
you think this is the biggest story in a
uh of Our Generation 100 I 911 we might
be the general I think I'm in a
generation different slight from you
like I was the end of X you're the
beginning of the next one so for me it
was 9 11. 911 because it was sending we
still didn't know it was like three
years that we didn't understand 911
which was made it much worse this at
least we have light on it right now 911
was catastrophic but it brought the
country more together this is for Our
Generation something that is the most
divisive in our country there's an
argument to be made that 911 is what set
all of this in motion so 911 the United
States the response the United States
has to 911 where the U.S really really
clamps down on on data data and
information and stuff like that and
spying and really violates the
Constitution I think that there's an
argument to be made that 911 changed
America so much that made this moment
possible but at the same time uh it is
reasonable to say that the the clear
political uh you know attack on the
president by putting your political
opponent in jail that is a watershed
moment that is without question if it's
if it's not the most uh impactful
um and I think it remains to be seen
whether or not it will be I if it's not
it's definitely among the top two or
three or do you say oh sorry would you
say that it's coordinated like brag is
like coordinating with the we were
talking about this earlier in like a
Twitter space or whatever but do you
think it's coordinated like Bragg is
working with the Democrat Party or he
it's just like a road a rogue actor
doing it just for himself because you
know he that's what he ran on and he
wants to make a name for himself but the
vibe I get is that it's that it's
coordinated or at least planned or that
it's because I was re-watching the
debates between Hillary and Donald again
like I watched a little before and you
know there's a whole thing of she's
talking glad you're not in charge of the
law and he's like because you'd be in
jail then another segment they're
debating and Donald's like you know I
didn't want to say this but I'm gonna
say it when I get into Power I'm going
to have a special prosecutor look into
your emails like he was totally telling
her on stage I'm gonna charge I'm gonna
go after you and investigate you when I
become president so like he opened the
gates to this well he didn't do it
though he did he didn't do it and we
should now I mean there should be he
should have done it he should have he
should have 100 I don't know I think the
president's bad whoever does it because
he should have done it as an attack on
the bureaucracy it it is not because
because the secretary of state is a
bureaucratic position right so Hillary
Clinton was the Secretary of State
that's when she that's when she uh ask
the the or The Story Goes that he
doesn't he chickened out yeah he did he
got in and then he's like no no we're
not going to do that we're not going to
do that and then behind closed doors
they were sitting there saying
themselves we have to crush him in any
way possible
they tweeted that what was it the day he
got inaugurated they were going to
impeach him 100 the lawyer who was
involved in the first impeachment
tweeted at him we will impeach you they
had been working non-stop to make up a
reason to go after him and now that he's
running again and they know he's doing
well in the polls this is what they do
136 years in prison I don't I think they
would have done this regardless of how
he was doing in the polls to be honest
absolutely because they I think that
this is punishment I think that this is
punishment from The Establishment to you
know punishing Donald Trump and you know
the January 6th there's the same thing
the reason that they you know sat in
jail for trespassing charges you know
unprecedented treatment uh for for
trespassing and the like is is because
of it is you it is the government
punishing people that would challenge
their Authority even if you would
ostensibly use your own you know use
things that are you know actions that
are protected by the Constitution to get
people used to that type of behavior and
persecution and to scare them like so
you know everybody was saying don't go
out and protest it's a trap Feds all
that kind of thing well that's exactly
what they wanted to do they wanted to
scare you and think that it was feds and
that you needed to stay home and that if
you did go out it was going to go crazy
and you were going to be arrested and so
effectively they got what they wanted
either way either you stay home and you
don't do anything and you're safe or you
go out and you know that you're the
government's going to be weaponized
against you and everybody especially on
the left is okay with that yeah it these
are all political litmus tests or or
um you know population lit necessity how
much the people will put up well so I
asked Charlie crickets the other day
I'll ask you Lisa do you think Trump
gets convicted yes I'll tell you why I
mean absolutely we have we have this
first of all the judge needs to recuse
himself because of his daughter but even
if he doesn't right why because of his
daughter his daughter is
um working for Kamal Harris the judge's
daughter is working with Kamal Harris so
she needs to he needs to recuse himself
clearly I don't think that's going to
happen but that's what needs to be done
but I've been in I've actually been on
trial and my judge like I was in for a
trade secrets case and my judge
specifically said because you
hyperlinked the where the information
was publicly available you're not
allowed instead of like showing them
screenshots of the actual websites
you're not allowed to tell the jury that
at all I'm like well it's a trade
secrets case and if it's public and I
can show that it's public on the
internet then how can I not present that
to the jury he didn't like my attorney
but I mean we still won but like I was
not allowed to tell the jury that all
this information was publicly available
on websites these for motions and
lemonade which is what the jury's
allowed to say the judge can rule on
almost anything not being presented to
the jury as like bias or whatever they
want yes but let me add you could
literally show the jury a video
recording of Michael Cohen smoking a
cigar being like you know the nice thing
I'm gonna do is yeah I'm gonna falsely
accuse Trump get him locked up that's
not a jury and the jury is going to be
like yeah I don't care Trump goes to
prison agreed agreed so that was the
second part so a even if you have one
like you know righty on the jury pool
you have a judge that's already likely
going to bias the information that he
gives the jury and then look where
you're pulling from so I know that
they're trying to get it um the case
transferred to Staten Island or
something like that they're going to put
a motion in for that emotion to dismiss
but we both know that this judge isn't
going to approve any of that I have a
desperate plea to the Deep State and the
shadow government listening you guys
this is too much like Nazi Germany the
the people no screaming out about the
Communist liberal Democrats just like
the Nazis were screaming about the
Communist liberal Democrats people
screaming out about the fake news nope
like the like Gobles are screaming about
the fake news and then they put when
they put Hitler in jail is when he
became very radicalized and you do not
want to do that to someone that 40
million people are following right now
right now there's like three deep State
guys and one guy sitting there in a
single tier goes on his cheek and he's
like he's right you guys we gotta call
this off no it's not
it's a noble noble statement to make but
this is this is exactly what they want
and there are people that given the
opportunity would put Donald will put
Donald Trump away for the rest of his
life you know no question but I do got
to say part of me is imagining this
future where like it's 300 years and
there's like a space station and this
teacher has got a bunch of little future
kids and she's walking up to a giant
statue of Ian in the space Colony
orbital ship and she's like before the
start of the second Civil War one person
fought to keep this country United and
it was only after years of fighting did
he finally reunite the country and save
Earth that's just like a big Ian wearing
a purple Blazer look at his face he's
like oh god I've been having visions put
me in touch with the shadow government
there's a deep state that is like the
administrative state but then there's a
this according to Alex Jones I asked
them the difference between the Deep
State and the shadow government he said
the shadow government's like a
government that has its own military its
own up everything existing beyond all
countries that is there just in case
there's a nuclear war they'll keep
continuity of government yeah I'm
talking to yeah The Enclave I want to
get in touch with you guys help you
build space force defend against drone
swarms make the world peace for real
we believe you you look you look very
sincere so there's repurpose the
military industrial complex to start
building drone what we need to focus on
drones and not blowing up humans sorry
Tim what were you saying I'll say he's a
president National Security Presidential
Directive 51 I believe it was
the division games are based on this
that in the event of catastrophic loss
of human life or economic damage the
president can create a new government
replacing the U.S government
that's that's something that George W
bush created and it's never been tested
but it it can never be tested in the
event that some catastrophic moment
happens maybe the dollar collapses or
something economy we're a Great
Depression they'll just do it and no one
will be able to challenge them it's just
it's just that I imagine they're
underground because it's for nuclear
well Alex said it was for nuclear war
like the surface gets totaled it's
supposed to keep Humanity going well not
Humanity the government yep yes
government yeah and henceforth Humanity
utilitarian view yeah I mean it is it is
humanity is second order I will continue
I should say the the humanity is the
fact that Humanity gets you know
continues is a byproduct of the
government continuing they want the
government to continue they need people
so that if they could have ai do it and
like only a couple people they would be
fine with that I don't know if I brought
this up on the show I think we truly
could repurpose our military-industrial
complex Boeing who's we uh the United
whoever the people that run Lockheed we
could be like okay instead of building
they don't want to missiles lives are
better the way their lives are better
building but think about the Drone
storms that are coming because
drones and then take them out into space
arm them with like laser sensors so they
don't have weapons they can just tag us
with lasers and put onboard AI on these
drones they can swarm our Pilots or our
drones and tell us what we're doing
wrong and how to get better at fighting
drone swarms thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time